ووضع نظاما سياسيا كل من جاء وبعده من
الدول والممالك في العالم الاسلامي كلها
استمرت عليه الدوله الامويه وضعت نظما
ودواوين من جاءوا بعدهم له يعودون اليهم
فقط وسعوا ويعودون الى هذا الاساس عفوا
هذا النظام الذي وضعه معاي بن ابي سفيان
هو انه حينما حدثت احداث الفتنه
والاضطرابات كان لابد من وضع نظام سياسي
وتاسيس نظام سياسي ينقذ العالم الاسلامي
من الاضطراب والتفكك فاسس معاويه ابن ابي
سفيان اول عائله ملكيه وراثيه تحكم في
تاريخ الاسلام هناك ناس غضبوا كثيرا من
هذا النظام وانه تغيير في نظام حكم
الخلافه على الراشده جميل من حقك ان تختلف
مع اي نظام سياسي ولكن كل الدول العباسيه
بعد ذلك
التي بعد الدوله الامويه
التزمت بنفس النهج وبحذافي
ره ودول ملكيه وراثيه وتسمي نفسها ايضا
بنفس الاسم على اسم
الدوله الامويه ثم الدوله العباسيه ثم
الدوله الفاطميه ايضا وهم دوله وهم
اسماعيليه شيعه مع ذلك التزموا بهذا
النظام الذي وضعه معاويه اذا كان لديهم
مشكله مع هذا النظام حقيقيه وهذا النظام
لم يكن ناجح فعلا في ذلك الوقت لماذا
حينما كان لهم الامر لماذا لم يغيروه
لماذا لم يلغوه الحقيقه انها كان نظام
ناجح وانقذ العالم الاسلامي